it's that special time of year again
folks no not Christmas taxis in Ramadan
or international hot dog appreciation
day it's fifa demo time the first time
that footy fans around the world get to
play the latest fifa in the comfort of
their own homes and then go online and
complain that they basically reskinned
the same game as last year but if you
like me and you play fifa every single
day like it's got the bloody antidote in
it you're probably interested in just
what's been changed in FIFA 15 because
when you play a game this much little
changes can be vast improvements and
emissions can be deeply frustrating the
demo opens at you playing as Liverpool
in an field in a title clinching final
game of the Premier League season
against Man City this is not only a way
for EA sports head Peter Moores in the
back pure fantasy but on Felix is a
pretty good stage to show off the great
new stadium atmosphere on show in this
year's version now once you start if
you're wondering why a man city are
playing more like Exeter City it's
because the initial demo game is locked
to semi-pro difficulty so don't feel too
great when you split open the city
defense to win the league with a Ricky
Lambert screamer you can pump up the
difficulty once this first demo game is
over oh and if you're an old pro
evolution fan make sure you swap at your
controls before you launch a tap-in over
the bar I played the demo on PC which
unlike last year's edition plays on the
new ignite engine so it looks and feels
similar to last year's next-gen outing
that said handling is better players run
into stupid positions a hell of a lot
less and an increased emphasis on
one-on-ones means defending is a lot
trickier than last year's game to play
is smoother first touches or less random
an individual players feel capable of
running at the opposition then again the
demo only has top-flight teams so who
knows how shamrock rovers or Mansfield
handle in game tactics now include
all-out attack and park the boss dead
ball situations now include tactics
modifiers or you can decide to play as
an outfielder and ask to receive the
ball pitches get worn in as the game
progresses jerseys get wet and muddy you
can pick snowy weather if you want but
they forgot to put the orange ball in
the demo so only do it if you want to
lose sight of the default white one
every fight
seconds oh and the dead fish is back
yeah dead fish the camera cuts away to
these nice vanity shots a lot more the
half time whistle and idling in the menu
music kicks off this nice slow-mo high
contrast demo reel menus have been given
a facelift to with player stats and
photos more upfront they even stuck in
photos from martin Tyler and allen Smith
oddly enough specific details on player
injuries it used to be in the squad menu
don't appear anymore which makes it
harder to decide whether you should take
off Xavi once he's randomly walked off
the pitch after being tackled why are
you waving at me I are you injured are
you badly injured I'll bloody holly's
walk back on so it's not without its
idiosyncrasies but the on pitch action
in 15 does seem better than last year's
at least in terms of modes I guess we'll
have to wait and see the bizarrely
omitted tournament mode and guest play
will be returning it's not sure about
unripe friendlies though but you can
expect a shed load more ultimate team
stuff and based on all these menu
changes in the demo hopefully a better
interface for career mode thanks for
watching those are my thoughts on a
course we'll have a review of p215 on
gamespot com once it's out what do you
guys think let us know in the comment